what up this is the kid Machine Gun
Kelly wabula keV please stop [__]
dogs in the ass Ready Set Radio bootleg
keV live in studio right now this guy is
a man to make it so much noise just on
the bt cypher ain't gonna lace up we're
out here alright bro so your vegas is
the first time you've been here what if
first on foursquare are some festivities
you have participated in thus far uh it
is the typical debauchery just wrong you
know the other night I was chugging Jack
Daniels off a girl's breasts oh damn
well that sounds fine mmm i'll try to
see donkey having such the girl with a
said that only happens with over the
border yeah you gotta go to Mexico yeah
that's what they told me but I thought
it was the vaguest thing but I wish what
else strip clubs for sure wish I was in
a strip club until my CD release
yesterday so you were just chillin until
over there so like the rage back came
out and now yeah so the mixtape just
came out like you said the rage mooon um
I noticed your wild boys on their yeah
um do you guys have the radio edit of
wobbly yes we do okay guy before you and
we do have it pressure you guys to play
it wasit hunts pool I like how you paste
pay how much the Steve away is that like
a jacket right here I see that okay
actually I grow thing I grew up
idolizing those guys yeah see me it was
always like jackass and Tom Green look
you know and I'm sorry hungry as I was
throwback that's the throwback right
there that's that's the original jackass
bum is on your lid Freddy got fingered
for the win um hey so uh manuu of course
you signed with Diddy right now you're
you're popping man um why don't you
speak on like you're crazy fan base cuz
I'll be seeing cats with tattoos of you
know lace up in your face and hmm when
did that stuff starts alike happen
definitely a probably January this year
it started happening than just a man
grew so what was so gross so crazy I
mean every show we do there's lace up
tattoos in the crowd the face one was
not so like with ya face off that was
amazing that's actually you know every
time around that guy's area they him and
his wife always come out and we always
you know we have a good time so you know
it's me I don't know the autograph thing
is becoming crazy crazy like I'll sign
people and they'll get it autographed
tattooed on them that's not yeah man I
don't know but but
I'd still like it's like it's such a
it's so it's so cold but you know
there's pros and cons I mean we're still
very we're not as major as you would
think you know like I mean we're making
a lot of noise but I mean it's still not
where I wanted to be you know like God
definitely I mean like like I'd always
heard of you but like I'd say over the
last six months I started so yeah
noticed a yeah when I started to notice
you and you know what do you think matru
these two I mean because I like someone
like tech nine it kind of has that same
kind of cult following right on a larger
scale um do you think it's just how you
interact with your fans what you do for
the fans that kind of gives them that
bond to you yeah but yeah it is it's a
hundred percent just us being so
personal with them I think being take up
the same problem no I think that you
know that the industry is kind of scared
to take a chance right on me in tech
like I think they're both like we're
both on the same boat because no one
wants to take that leap in cosine this
person so I mean I perceived no cosines
you know I thought the puff cosine I
didn't think this at all but you know
you would think the puff cosine we're
just like immediately just break you to
everybody else but everyone else is just
like dude you know like that mean
everyone's kind of hands out plus were
super while to like release you know
we're really wild and we just like you
know it's kinda like we're very like
family-oriented meaning like we know we
can't hang out with ourselves we're not
really like all like you know strangely
yeah you know the exact you know we're
not really know I don't really have
anyones bumps on my lips all right I
mean where did we just value just
everyone that like so you know just like
for you inviting us out here I mean
really I mean on national level even
especially Vegas you know we're not
really anything so for you thanks to the
radio station is awesome and hopefully
you know I get the PDS report so I mean
I know that we have a long way to go
because yeah I mean I respect the
movement I'm not gonna lie I have it
like I've listened to your music but I
haven't there hasn't I haven't listened
to enough of it to like sick cause don't
call myself a fan you don't want to
front cuz I'll you know cuz you're right
here um but I have checked out you know
some stuff and what was the song on the
new mixtape was it concrete something
chasing pavements chasing pavement yeah
that song was hot yeah that's like songs
like that or what makes like like fans
are my like super super right now
because I feel like you know the
personal thing which is I feel sucks
because I feel like a lot of other
artists now like see that it works for
me and they have a bigger platform so
they do it and like more people look at
their stuff and don't pay Han as
that came from us doing that first now
you're from Cleveland um of course
there's a lot you know there's not a lot
of people from Cleveland that are doing
music but the most notably blow both do
and I saw kid cudi had kind of you and
him I don't know if I saw he kind of
made a statement that seemed to be
loosely directed towards you about the
whole raging thing um is is that like
cuz i know i mean i'm sure you i mean
kid cudi's been mr. rager for a while um
but I know you've been doing your thing
for a while it just hasn't been on I
think a lot of time again this is like
we're just not on national race that's
what I'm saying I think a lot of times
because you're just starting to come to
the throne people that you like you just
started making music yesterday like I
mean I could make one ever want to do in
the crowd so everything now because we
started that right so I guess my
question is like well someone I Cudi um
I mean is that like considering from
your city does that I mean does it hurt
that you know he's kind of it's always
it's always a bummer when like people
that uh you know when you're the young
guy and you expect you know you want
some especially I Cleveland this and
it's not necessary son the map but it's
not really well known as described in
the bucket syndrome there to you know
people got it just like like the city
will just pull you down pull you down we
have a really good great situation cuz
we have so much hometown love because
it's kind of like you said about DMX in
Arizona like we're all work you can see
it's out all the time but a new kind of
sucks I mean it's all good though like I
mean like I'm just looking forward to
you know someone huge coming out and
saying they don't like me to make more
famous yeah that is that's always a good
little works that's how it works and
it's funny because I tweeted you know if
anybody had anything to ask you and I
got so many tweets involved in yellow
wolf do you get your your your young
white dude up and coming with a lot of
tattoos he's young why do double coming
with a lot of tats right um do you feel
like is it is it annoying that like you
get compared you guys good please shut
its pretty disillusioned pretty new
because I mean I'm a big I mean I i I'm
my home is with yellow if you know easy
I'm a big fan his music and I don't
really see the young comparison all
except you guys is physical appearance
you know what I'm saying there's a
little bit but yeah let me see only see
the only blonde hair blue eyed like
Midwest boy I mean
on the deep voice deep raspy voice yeah
you know sound like I don't see the
comparison what is um I mean in the next
year man what is the plan to like I
guess separate yourself from from the
pack I know you already kind of our but
I mean we could we got we oh we kind of
like we're kinda like punk rockers
actually so yeah I mean I already think
that that separators I mean but and I
kind of see hip-hop trying to do that
but you know we're genuine with it I
just I mean I am for sure I grew up on
that stuff so I mean you know just just
throwing things like you know getting
kicked out the hard rock hotel two
nights ago oh nice should we do are we
shut down we stay shut down the whole
show I mean you know we got got wild
fights broke out we jump in the pool
front flip to the pool yes for so long
you know smash watermelons and you know
all that other stuff so we just just
doing things I just so you know the hip
hop is missed for a long time I even
like there hasn't been any dope like
like rock accident not like someone on
roll [__] yeah yeah that's what that's
many people ruin in hotel rooms and you
know I mean what what happened is that
it came back to life right years yeah so
you go my hotel room right now it's
embarrassing he said man it is
embarrassing Reyes worst yeah that see
that and that's that's dope man um I
also want to ask you about your
influences because you know you're from
the midwest saloon you know you got that
that rapid-fire flow um naturally I I
you know of course probably like bones
all is to those kind of guys who are
some of your influences that people I
guess would be surprised by uh I just
brought Adele's hour long as it's
amazing Adele's dope 21 I mean it was a
crazy album I'm really into 10 million
civilians like like event like I mean
like I said I about to go check out the
avenged sevenfold show I'm actually you
know friends with her with the lead
singer and all the stuff so I mean I'm
about to go check their show out I'm
really big fans not been fans of them
since we 7 7th 8th grade okay yeah well
for a while no blink blink just like man
I just missed them they were in town
yeah there they dedicated what's my age
again to me on stage in Cleveland that's
dumb do you know because we always end
our shows with what's my age again so uh
Aaron it yeah so like I mean like don't
you know I don't know if anyone I mean I
you probably look at me and assuming all
those little things but anyway again I
mean I'm a Bigfoot I do
hey um another question I want to ask
you when you first time with Diddy I
know did he kind of has not the best
track record with artists like you know
Lou no he does not he really doesn't um
were you at we did that like was that
hesitant no it's been more hidden
anymore doing more okay cuz ya cuz I was
like damn like you got what it takes to
blow but you know sometimes Diddy is you
know he's dead he with his artists now
we have full control of ours or do plus
bad boy Interscope that's what cuz I
thought your own Interscope initial
actually it's my label son to bed
Williams go so it's EST 19xx / bad boys
let's go people don't understand that
either like you got full control yeah
like for controlling you see we're in
Vegas pups not here yeah he's doing he's
doing this thing I do my thing yeah he's
a marketing genius so you know I kind of
when it's time for him to push that
button like I'm a previous one but
everything that you're saying right now
is all us you know yeah like I mean I
doubt bad boys called to the radio
station has to play wild boy this is why
I'm here they have now play wobbly so
you know it's kind of all this time just
like all of us uh just doing our thing
and when it's time for them to push the
button I'll let them know and they'll
push it and I pray to God that we will
get famous or something change the world
really I wanted to ask you about the
flash mob you know yes all over the
place yet it was all over the internet
it's on worldstar I mean it was on every
blog yeah completed yeah I know watched
it it was so crazy cuz like like I've
never seen an artist just be so like
chilling with the fans yeah I'm all
about um how did how did that I mean how
did that come about would you just show
up somewhere with a megahorn ya papi
yeah I was getting a tattoo and i was i
was really bored i was like man which
also everyone is just means tomorrow i
had no clues gonna be like that it was
out of control and then uh yeah we just
I call I that's my camera guy right here
I told him as I come through there's
like this one scene and so funny
something news and when they did all the
news that's one is he like of him
running and he's like oh my god that's
him oh my god kid is him oh my god Kate
out there and uh yeah it was so weird we
just showed up and they're like tennis
form showed up there like fans between
like they got police with dogs here for
you it's a wrap for you when you come in
and we're just like damn like we know it
only down look let's just do it anyway
so we just went there they did paid the
bond got out have you thought
out like i don't know i guess the bonds
would it would add up but maybe doing
that and like every city I'll you know
I'll talk about that color sometimes we
almost be crazy we can't do one in
Cincinnati like we went out right before
the show they all fans on the line like
we drove pass out standing on top of a
car yeah I do like oh my god that's it
was cool Samantha BTW cyber uh you know
I thought you had the ill line the white
boy killer doble s controversial it was
a little a lot of oohs and all I thought
they were gonna blow I thought they're
gonna break it out yeah yeah I I was
like oh yeah okay they blanked out
coping strap that I was kind of pissed
ah I was all good though um when you
when you were because I saw online
skills was he skills was doing the
cipher everybody who did all the ciphers
were they everybody was there at the
same to know it was it was a it was like
you know it's the wildest part of it i
mean actually they were there there was
a certain artists inserted it was like
separate or anything like that but um
you know you got that when you got there
when at different call times well the
crazy part was like it takes like two
hours to do that cipher I can imagine
takes like two hours like the amount of
mess ups are insane well that's what
that's what I feel sad skills like crazy
is like I casarez messing up over and
over over over to them like man it's
like I'm some like 40 times did you keep
messing up I had like maybe like three
or four you cuz your cipher involved a
lot of like you know you had the spittin
in the you know I could imagine it'd be
hard to get that down on the first novel
the thing was I wrote it that morning in
the hotel room okay so on a piece of
paper so like until it was funny like
bothered by the second mess up by saying
that self I was like oh no I told on I
took the piece of paper out Evan was a
dying because like you know everyone
else is like yeah every time everyone
has a front like it's a real freestyle
like they do on the blackberry someone
like no dude what's obvious so like you
know about and it was funny because like
new known writes lyrics on paper anymore
so like I had my like a hotel pad and I
pull it out and everyone start rolling
in as good time that's well that's what
it is man machine gun kelly uh the
single wild boy it's crazy you got Waka
Flocka on there that's been selling a
lot of fights and clubs and stuff was
cool yeah that's why the thing oh no
it's a great thing on up there's extras
video should check outs called welcome
to the rage I put out like two days ago
it's really dope you appreciate it there
it is with the rage thing man to find
this rage hash trager's just
like negative energy and turning into
positive and also just getting in a
hotel ya filthy Lee ways Mickey custom
here guys edited breast bone [__] [__]
[__] what's the blinks all the [__] [__]
piss [__] [__] piss ass [__] suck
[__] you doing [__] yeah that's
what it is I wanna [__] a dog in the ass
yes I wanna [__] your mom in the ass
that is class I wanna [__] a dog we're
out here lazy ass lace-up yeah yeah yeah
you got a hit with the ham in there
there it is Machine Gun Kelly a thank
you for coming through man you thank you
you're real cool dude thank you oh my
god I gotta get on your music man like i
said yeah man please a little uh when
you start to get bigger everybody who
interviews is gonna try to suck you off
real heavy like they're all upon your
[__] note that you knows chris they
actually don't they don't but not yet
not at all not yet but when you get to
that next level of Fame it'll it'll
happen I still really don't see
happening and I still think I you know I
don't know I feel like I feel like you
either like this the smoking section is
just a great all right were article
right up on me they used to hate me at
blog they say hate me great website yes
yet it was your great website that she
used to dog me all the time and they end
up like you know the rage back in on
they wrote a great article about it now
it's like it was really cool it's cuz
you know because I knew they were
infamous for just disliking my [__] you
know they were just like you know you
either really love this guy you really
hate hate oh yeah there's island there's
no medium so it's like I leads to only
see the radio thing like going and
medium is just the latest at man are
locals only right here damn it most
painful one uh probably uh probably
Banksy piece right here or actually not
just a rabid I'm under own armpit was a
bad choice that's what it is no wasn't
bad choice alright man thanks for coming
to thank you man yes sir